[Music]
it might feel like this year has just
begun but it took CEOs just the first 33
hours of 2020 to earn the average
British workers entire annual salary by
the end of the year the average CEO will
have earned 117 times what the average
employee earns a footsie 100 CEO earns
144 times more than a nurse 142 times
more than a teacher and 150 times than
the police constable my question is this
would a footsie 100 CEO be less
productive or worse at their job if they
earn say 2 million a year instead of the
average three point four six million no
what if someone on minimum wage had an
extra grand to make their life run a
little bit more smoothly
yes new rules come into force this year
and firms with over 250 employees have
to disclose the ratio difference in pay
between their CEOs and their average
worker and justify why the gap is so big
I'm not saying mean a cap on the total
amount but might a cap on the ratio make
our country a fairer and more productive
place so I find this conversation this
narrative around comparing the footsie
100 CEO to the average wage of a nurse
and a firefighter I find it bizarre and
completely irrelevant and when you get
to the top of your game whatever your
game is the top and these 100 people
these are these are people who are
absolutely at the top of their game they
have made sacrifices they are not your
average worker in whatever sector they
are not average if they where average
they wouldn't be fielding those things
the footsie 100 and the progression
development and success of those footsie
100 companies benefits all pension
holders while most pension holders have
funds that are invested in footsie 100
companies so they need to do well now I
do believe that we should incentivize
people to be at the top of their game
when they're there and but I also agree
with the reporting mechanism of showing
the ratio gap because I think it starts
sessions in those conversations I hope
that you use the word irrelevant yes the
fact that we have CEOs earning whatever
millions and billionaires will be yeah
and to compare and to make the point
that it's it's irrelevant to compare the
fact that a nurse we have nurses who are
using food banks these days and it's not
an irrelevant injustice it was an
irrelevant injustice that people are on
food banks that is wrong what I said was
your comparison between a footsie 100 in
just which means the comparison there in
just literally means the comparison it
is unjust that we have that level of
wage disparity that's the point that's
the point we're making here the two are
not the same Rachel I think Michele
you're as it were your absolute adoption
of market principles is slightly
obscuring your sense of humanity and
justice in what is actually happening
I live in Notting Hill and I cannot
count the number of times I've sat next
to a man at dinner and I've said what do
you do and he says something like I work
at a med merchant bank or hedge fund and
then I ask him how much he earns and
he'll say tens of millions of pounds
eeeh and I say why is what you do worth
more than what the nurse in A&E who's
just treating my mother no wait Michelle
this is important their value they are
not the people who are whose pay is a
fraction a hundredth of these CEOs do
just as important work should be just as
much responsibility
yeah sure wait should I just finish off
they say I said I still don't understand
why what'd you do you're justified
taking home tens of millions and he said
because I am a David Beckham of the
financial world and I say that's funny
because as far as when I lost it there
was only one David Beckham but everyone
round this table is only tens of
millions before I bring anyone else it
and for the record my mum and sister
NHS workers right there you think they
were paid properly no that are paired
we're less than what they are worth they
work well just wait and I want those
nurses to be paid more you're I don't
always says the NHS needs to be cut back
and it's waste of what's that got to do
with my mom and sister been paid not
enough for their
what's that got to do with the average
footsie 100 CEO you taught footsie let's
talk football this this is six forum
debating stuff because sadly sadly the
world is not fair the world is not right
a Harry Maguire and Manchester United
makes one hundred and fifty thousand
pounds a week a nurse will dream of them
it's not fair but you're not going to
change it so sorry the entire debate was
about changing the fact that it's not
fair people didn't anything like this
and actually in the last twenty years
there's been incredible growth in these
people and I think and I think the
shareholders who haven't been strong
enough saying that it's you're now
owning too much and I think the reason
I'm finding too much the way to do it
though because it's not what they're
earning compared to so the hedge fund
guys it's nothing the engine guys are
earning way way more than that the
private equity can I do any way more
than that the way to do it is to have a
much more proven much more effective
taxation system and actually save you
earn that sort of money you're gonna pay
significantly more intact yeah can we
just hear from the thirty Francis
O'Grady the two you see as to why
actually we are workers in the economy
and why it's not fair that some people
take so much more of the goodies than
others what she says this tells you
everything about how unfair our economy
is every working person plays a part in
creating Britain's wealth but people at
the top are taking more than their share
we need a real plan from the government
to tackle excessive pay that's TC TC
General sec yeah I eat ginseng as a
coach f m-- and really led some you know
from the Tories saying today's fat-cat
day figures will be eye watering for
most people in the UK yeah the numbers
are lower than they were but still
concerning as well as our world-leading
legislation on excessive pay new reforms
this year would increase transparency
around directors responsibilities and
it's interesting that this is the Tory
party this is the Tory party that the
adopting American capitalism and in
yeah well one nation for a while but it
is interesting that the politicians in
the Tory party I was equally concerned
about what has happened to executive and
they are talking I mean I remember they
did talk about multiples I think my own
brother at one point said that the
lowest paid worker should not be paid
less than 1/8 of what the highest-paid
worker was something I may be wrong but
I remember coming down by the way it is
on the decline and I actually agree with
this transparency because I think that
once it's transparent this pay ratio I
think you'll start to see a correction
because I don't think people like things
it's not a socially popular situation to
have you know your CEOs on multiple
multiple multiple but I just I'm so
uncomfortable with the notion that
government step in and say right your
maximum ratio is this I think it'd be
counterproductive to business that's
when you do it through a taxation
shareholder power if they don't like it
they don't vote through these recall the
last successful shitlords the executive
pay Commission which has been sitting
for years and years and it still hasn't
come up with anything the government can
actually action I just want to bring
back the point you said about how these
CEOs they are responsible for lots and
many many jobs people are worth more
than they're worth and if you take if
you take for example a one in a
two-parent household one pair one parent
goes off and and and SAP does the
sacrifices you referred to of not really
seeing their kid that much or the other
parent stays home are we going to
pretend that that that stay-at-home
parent is less valuable to society
especially as a that pet the parenting
parenting within it wouldn't societies
as playing a vital role be there
sacrifices in terms of their career is
actually enabling that to put t100 do
then go off and earn the millions and
employ all those people that he does I
just think you've got more I just think
your comparisons are irrelevant that if
you want to have a conversation about
raising minimum wage and doing that
that's not a problem I would agree that
many people are underweight i underpaid
i agree with all of that I just dislike
this comparison because I think it's
politics of envy and it just confuses
the the conversation no n look you and I
whilst we agree on the things we
disagree on the comparison so let's cash
in this debate
see what I did there and move on there
are certain places that tourists just
must visit when they're in the UK as one
American student found out Malory
bata went viral after she posted a video
of herself online checking out one of
the most iconic locations Britain has to
offer full of herp and glory and pints
for less than two quid that's right
where the spoon is look at this okay so
the place that I found that interests me
the most
it's called Wetherspoons in England and
it's so freakin good
let's see what you got okay so it's like
really really cheap I'm gonna get the
vegetarian breakfast it's only at that
amount and then I'm home and then you
get free refills it's amazing I do this
as many times as you want okay so we got
all of this food plus the coffee for ten
pounds and make sure you put the beans
on the toast this is freaking amazing
for showcasing the best of what this
country has to offer
Mallory you are straight talker of the
week wondering what Weatherspoon's was
have you ever been any more many times
I'm a great I love a spinster but I
don't think we should be running these
long adverts from their products too
many of those bits you might be a
straight tool because you won't be a
straight walker right I'm going for a
pint that's all we've got time for the
three so if you want to join the debate
to search for the pledge from Spitzer
and don't forget you can take the debate
with you by listening to us on Apple
podcasts Spotify or whichever app you
for fair thanks for watching
[Music]